programming
thank you uh john and thank you for the
organizers for giving me this
opportunity to talk
and for also i thank you to stay that
you stayed here uh late uh in the
afternoon and i i'm gonna i'm gonna
hopefully finish by five so you can go
and have your first beer by 5 30.
okay
so i'll talk about the degree of central
care in quadratic programming and this
is joint work with one of my master's
students
now he's done and he's he's a phd
student at carnegie mellon or department
and uh you know uh
part of his thesis is sort of part of
what i'm going to talk about today okay
um so what's a quadratic program
quadratic programming is a is an
optimization problem okay we're trying
to minimize uh
a quadratic objective function okay
given by
a uh a n by n
symmetric positive definite matrix and
then there's also linear part two
subject to linear equations and and then
variables are non-negative okay again in
this case the q is a positive definite
matrix you know c is a
some some cost vector a is a d by a
matrix uh of of rank d so keep in mind
you know d is the number of equations
and n is the number of variables so you
know in my formulas you know the d and n
are going to appear okay
um so as i stated this is a convex
optimization problem because when i have
a positive definite matrix up there it's
got convex objective function and
feasible region is also convex this is
sort of the
all the nice technology we can apply
right uh um of optimization to convex
optimization okay so how would you solve
such a problem okay here's one way of
solving so like a 10 000 feet uh point
of view of interior point methods you
change your object your uh problem just
slightly you know you put in the
the non-negativity constraints in the
into the objective function okay um
lambda is a is a positive parameter
there right now uh as lambda
so you should imagine that you're gonna
solve this problem okay as lambda starts
big you know plus infinity is gonna go
down to zero uh objective function is
still convex okay
and when lambda is really super big okay
then we can get the optimal solution for
this problem very easily because the the
the original objective function parts of
disappears you know it's not gonna
affect and then as lambda goes down to
zero the original objective function is
going to take over right and we'd like
to sort of use that and uh how can you
so turn this into equations right
optimization problems is really
solving systems of equations right i can
write down the what's called the kkt
conditions encourage contact conditions
and here they are you know the first two
are the feasibility conditions on x x
equal to b x dot negative and then comes
sort of the the uh gradient of the
objective function
okay that's this first part there and
then that's equal to
a a linear combination of the rows of
the matrix a okay so y is a vector of
variables you know y one through y d so
there are dv the other y values there so
the nice thing is that so we have a
convex problem so if
if you solve this problem it's going to
be a unique solution when lambda for
each lambda it's positive okay and the x
component of that
of that uh of that solution is going to
give you an optimal solution for the
above problem there
okay so we're going to
we're going to do that and so so again
for every lambda there's a unique
solution so for a lambda there's some
some solution here where x star is going
to be the optimal solution up there okay
and then we can vary the lambda right
and plot the
the the pair of
optimum so actually the y sort of the
optimal solution for the for the dual
okay we can plot that and i'm going to
get a curve in r to the n plus one plus
d
okay
um
so uh this is a small example that i'm
gonna use to illustrate some of my
things here okay here's a quadratic
optimization problem very simple
quadratic function there so the q matrix
is actually a diagonal matrix now
okay and a linear part and then two
equations and four variables as you can
see you know i chose my equation such a
way so that x3 and x4 can be easily
expressed in terms of x1 and x2 just
stupid question on the last slide to
make sure i'm not lost
so
your actual solution is just the um
for
the
first solution where all the x's are
positive with the smallest lambda
because you have this curve and that's
the point on the curfew tape
again so so the lambda is super big yeah
when lambda is zero you know that
positivity but eventually it's going to
force it to be positive and you're
saying that first point is forced to be
positive is the actual solution to your
original question on the previous slide
now what i'm saying is i start with uh
with lambda being super big okay i i
solve a sequence of problems as lambda
is approaching zero okay i'm going to
also approach the optimal solution to
the original problem why does that keep
the x positive as lambda goes to zero
because of the logs
oh oh oh oh it's a barrier function
yeah okay sorry sorry okay okay so
that's my my problem so again so after
that i'll come back to my uh example
right away uh let me make a you know
central definition okay central
definition of central path okay so uh
okay so uh uh the uh if i take this
curve that i get for every lambda right
uh
at every point i get the point on this
curve for every lambda i take that and i
project it on the x coordinates okay get
a real curve that's called the central
path of quadratic programming
now meanwhile okay maybe uh i should
have said earlier in my original
optimization problem the quadratic
program of course if i didn't have the
quadratic part if q were equal to zero
right
then i will have a linear program okay
so what i'm saying here can be all set
for the linear programs as well okay so
the central path
um can be defined in a similar way using
the same kind of object
optimization problem okay
and and we'll get a central path for
linear programming too okay so what so
what are the equations defining my what
these are the kkt equations um said
defining the central path in my in my
problem okay so you see the diagonal two
matrix here
uh you see the the cost vector c up
there okay the lambda over the variables
uh appear there as well and you right
here you see the the transpose of the a
matrix and then the constraints the a
called x equal to b constraint down
there too okay so we solve this for
every lambda we get a curve
projected on x that's the central path
okay
so how would we use this so here's a is
a cartoon
idea okay and uh
um
when lambda is really big okay we can
solve the problem uh very easily and we
get something called analytic center of
the feasible region of the polar top
okay and then we start from there and we
start uh
making the lambda smaller as we're doing
that we're gonna we're going to trace
we're going to follow the central path
okay all the way to the optimal solution
okay so that's one
you know way of saying what how how the
inter point algorithms work
um in this you know cartoon picture you
know you should not be fooled okay i'm
sorry i had again the linear programming
in mind and the optimum source is going
to be at the vertex of course it doesn't
have to be that way okay
for the quadratic programming and
there's a unique optimal solution
somewhere but it doesn't have to be at
the corner there
but that's how the linear programs the
interior point algorithms work okay
okay so now let me go to uh uh the
algebra or algebraic geometry um uh you
know i define the central path by
projecting the earlier curve on the on
the x coordinates now about the
equations defining it were not
polynomial equations i'm going to make
them polynomial equations by clearing
the denominators okay so what you see
here is the kkt conditions equations but
i'm going to multiply each equation by
the corresponding x i because they were
in the denominator and i just polynomial
equations okay
so and i'll take the uh the so the
complex solution set of them together
with the x equal to b
that's a curve in c to the n plus one
plus d i'll project that on the the
first n coordinates i'm going to call
this the central curve or quadratic
program
all right
okay so this is
sent to curve defined by those equations
i cleared the denominators
okay so one more time
i'll project
uh
so the the ideal genetic by these
equations i'm going to call j and i'll
the the ideal the the vanishing ideal or
the idea that that of polynomial is
vanishing on the on the projection the
central curve i'm going to call i sub c
um
okay so in our running example okay if
you do the the computations uh there was
a n for it was equal to four d is equal
to two two equations for
for uh two equations and variables uh
the central curve after you do this
projection it will be defined by the
linear equations x equal to p and one
extra polynomial okay of degree four
okay this is that
and uh
um and you see the
the real uh picture of the curve
uh the the the
the wall is the ax equal to b two
dimensional defined space the lines you
see
are the intersection of the coordinate
hyperplanes with the
with the defined space our feasible
region original feasible region is this
quadrangle by the way okay that's the
one and you see the other feasible
regions there if i change the signs of
the of the variables and the rest you
know the curvy stuff is the central
curve
okay
and central curve contains all the
central paths of all the feasible
regions
okay and central paths will follow from
the analytic center of that particle
region to the optimal solution
sector
okay so it's a nice degree four curve
okay if you only cared about one of the
regions could you have a simpler curve
so the central curve is the way i
defined
is uh
i take the i forget about the
non-negativity you know i went to the
the complex numbers i take the whole
thing and then and then project it so i
get the wholeness
okay so
i think so okay
this is an introducible cure okay yeah
this is closer right so i guess the
other bonded chambers if you change the
sciences and variables those of them be
feasible regions exactly yeah so there
are so one of those there's two
components of the curve
right the triangle that's just below
your quadrant i mean this one here
no no no lower left
lower up no no no no no
here
maybe so i i'm not sure it's actually
the coordinate that's not those lines
are the coordinate axes
oh i'm sorry these are not the parts of
the curve yeah these are coordinate axes
oh okay
that's a probably it's a polynomial
decomposition of the plane and for
different choices of say yes changing
the science that's right each one of
these has become a feasible region
that's right yeah that feasible reason
that triangular region there's two
components of your central curve but
they're saying that these these are
coordinates it's not part of the pieces
not part of the conditions i think
i'm not sure why answer why the two to
two components there but
so there's there's also this quadratic
form has some minimum over all of
the plane the plane yeah i know what it
is
it's in it's in here actually the
original feasible region okay and it's
not on the boundary it's somewhere in
the middle here somewhere there and the
central path follows you know from
analytic center down there
yes
it's not everything else all the optimal
solutions are for all the feasible
regions are on the boundary except that
middle guy okay
okay so the goal uh here is
um
i like to compute the equations of the
central curve okay
and try to compute the degree of this
curve okay that's why the degree of the
central curve um so why
okay so this work of uh studying the the
central curve and interior point methods
uh using differential geometric methods
were started actually by
uh
um dave bayer and jeff lagarius in the
late 80s
uh but then sort of uh recently okay two
new things seven
uh um one of them is that uh um my uh
office mate gregorio malovich and uh
mike schuben and uh did you how did i
say to
you okay uh it's in 2005 um um looked at
the the central path and it looked at
the the total curvature okay of the
central path
for linear programs so why would you
want to look at the total curvature of
the of of of this curve uh well you know
as i just described to you oops the
other way okay um let's go back to the
cartoon okay so if i'm going to follow
this path
right i have to make steps
right i cannot continuously deform you
know lambda from positive infinity to
two to zero i have to make steps so that
means i'm going to be approximating this
curve by by a polygonal path
okay the curvier the path the higher the
the total curvature it's going to be
more difficult so the higher the
curvature the taller curvature then
there's going to be the the interior
point algorithm are going to take more
time more iterations to get to the
optimal solution okay so that's the
rough idea um so they looked at that
and
so their their idea was that well okay
the total curvature is actually can be
computed by looking at the the arc
length of the of the corresponding gauss
curve okay so you look at the
the the unit tangent vectors to the
curve you plot them on the on the unit
sphere and you compute the arc length
and that arc length can be bounded okay
can be bounded
uh by data coming from the central curve
itself including the degree okay
so that was the idea okay and then comes
uh jesus and parenting and cynthia okay
in 2012 actually earlier that's
published in 2012 and they actually gave
a bound okay
for the for the central curve uh in
terms of dnn okay
so the they say that the degree of the
central cure for linear programming is n
minus one choose d n is the number of
variables these the number of equations
okay and uh and this boundary sort of
exact when all the data
you know the a matrix the b and c and
everything is is generic okay if it's
randomly chosen
okay so that's the degree of the central
curve in particular it implies a bound
on the on the total curvature that i'm
just putting down there okay
all right
so that's a it's about on center
curvature now one of the motivations of
all the study is that there's been a
a a conjecture in the back you know and
out there it's called continuous huge
conjecture okay that says that
uh for any d okay you don't have to fix
okay for any d the the the for linear
programming the um this the total
curvature should be should be a linear
function in n
okay if we're bounded by that uh it
turns out it's a very new result by uh
mikhail osviken and his his quarters
that actually spectacular defaults
it's very the the total curvature of the
linear programming can be exponential
okay if you allow d to also vary yeah
and it's very interesting uh paper you
know i i have to look at it more
carefully but it involves heavy duty
top tropical geometry in there
and then finally you know my one of my
motivations here is that is that you
know quadratic programming so we deal
with linear programs uh the ultimate
goal is really you know look at
semi-definite programming it has its own
central curve and whatnot okay and
quadratic programming is a one step in
between okay although of course quite
seven different programming is a little
far away from from quadratic programming
in a sense and i know you know smart
people like you know cynthia have
thought about it and
it's a it's a hard problem but that's
sort of the goal
okay so i hope the the problem is clear
i'm going to look at the equations of
the central curve for for quadratic
programming computer degree
and uh and uh yeah so and these are the
reasons okay
okay so this is my uh embarrassing slide
okay ben already mentioned whether this
curve has to is is really reducible or
not
hey um
today i don't know okay in generality it
should be reducible but uh here is a one
one simple uh observation i'm gonna use
uh this says that if i take the upstairs
curve and remove the coordinate
hyperplanes
and then and then close back again
nothing changes which means that
which means that the central code does
not have any components if there are any
in the coordinate hyperplanes okay
of course if we're very reducible we're
fine you know that one is not going to
happen okay and uh and but the only
thing i'm using is is is this result
anyway okay
but i i agree with parent that the the
this curve should be should be
irreducible in general
okay
okay so here's our first uh observation
okay so now we're going to you know
parent and vince cynthia and jesus have
a way of computing the the degree using
some metroid theoretic methods okay n
minus one choose d is actually the
number of
uh bounded regions inside a real
hyperplane arrangement okay that comes
from a and b and c okay but we're going
to sort of now
move away from that idea and here's my
as our first result okay it says that um
if i want to compute the degree of the
of the central curve right what i would
do i would intersect it with a with a
random hyperplane and count the number
of points
right
it turns out
all i can i can do is i can take the
upstairs curve
and and intersect it with with a
hyperplane okay only in axis okay then
the number of solutions in the torus in
the corresponding torus is going to be
equal to the number of solutions
downstairs and that's exactly the degree
okay
so so why do you only intersect with the
x's and not with the generic okay so one
more time if i if i project it on the x
variables right then i get the central
curve and i want you know to compute
this degree degree i will intersect it
with a hyperplane like this what i'm
saying is that do the same thing
upstairs okay you will still have the
same number of intersection points
upstairs
okay
all right so another thing i have to
tell here this was actually crucial
point
it can't be several to one
no it's not it's not right it cannot
because of the
the ais here yeah the the a matrix there
all right so it's one to one and now one
more thing is to hear that um so i'm
assuming here by the way you know
everything is generic um but i already
in my example i was using a quadratic a
a diagonal uh matrix it turns out okay
if you replace everything in here where
you know everything is generated but q
is a is a diagonal matrix but generic
diagonal
entries then okay the the number of
solutions you would get for the
corresponding system is the same as
the number of solutions we get for the
for the general system now you might say
what's the big deal you know every
symmetric matrix can be turned into a
diagonal matrix but you know that's not
the reason here
because if you do that if you do that in
your uh let's see
okay you'll screw up your system
right back here if you do that one more
time if you make the change of
coordinates okay these these guys in the
denominator is going to become some
complicated linear forms
okay you have to clear those
denominators and the problem is going to
get complicated okay
so the reason why i can go down to go go
that the for the
that the number of solutions doesn't
change when i move to the diagonal uh uh
programs because i can have a homotopy
from this uh the general case to the
diagonal case okay so and nothing
happens in the sense that i don't lose
solutions if i if i when i do the
homotopic so this is very useful right
if you think about it if i want to
compute the numbers
right i can only use examples where the
diagonal the matrix is diagonal
okay and that makes the the uh uh the
computations a lot easier so when we
when we tried using grouping our basis
methods you know to eliminate and then
compute the degree we were able to
compute a very small portion of this of
this table so here these are the degrees
indicate for genetic cases where that d
is the number of equations and is the
number of variables okay we're able to
compute very small portion but with the
one
for the for the diagonal case we can
complete you know a big chunk of the
table okay and then
and in fact we did this earlier we
realized and then went back and approved
the earlier tier okay
okay so these are numbers hopefully you
you think that these numbers are nice
okay
all right very good
okay like the first row you know
fantastic
okay exactly oh wow frank's fast okay so
you see that right uh uh what is it
is that this is equal to that becomes
that you know it's uh it's very nice
all right so okay um okay so how we're
gonna do this i'm gonna do is i'm
supposed to count i'm supposed to count
the solutions in the taurus okay i'm
gonna do that for you first for the
linear program
right
um so this is the linear program version
so i'm going to compute for you the the
center the degree of the center for
linear program okay i need to count the
solutions here
um these are d plus one equations and n
variables
right i uh i change
make a change of uh i write the
solutions
um so this is a n minus one
n minus d minus one dimensional fine
space
right every solution looks like that so
v one through v n minus the
one is is a vector uh in the in the
kernel of the matrix
right so i introduce new variables t one
through t n times d minus one
hey i take that okay i plug it in
upstairs where i have the x's
okay i expanded out so i have n
equations now
in
n variables
and the support of those variables are
exactly these guys
okay so what are those i mean what the
sports of the equations okay note that
so the lambda you can i can ignore
okay 1
t 1 to t n minus t minus 1.
that thing multiplied with the y 1
that multiplied with y 2 etc okay that's
the that's the support
okay so what is the what is that
okay that's the uh
that's also known as the
the
the n minus d minus one simplex uh uh
cross uh d-dimensional simplex
and every equation has that has that uh
support so in order to compute the mixed
volume i'm gonna compute the normalized
volume i the volume of this guy okay the
volume of this guy
also known as the
as the
um
the kaley polo top
of uh
of uh uh
what is the d copies of n minus d minus
and one dimensional simplices obviously
d plus one copies of them
okay and the
and the uh um
the the volume is computed like that
it's actually n minus one choose d
okay and i'm gonna write it in this form
okay
so you can get this form
uh
as uh if you if you look at the
staircase triangulation
of the pull top
okay so this is not very complicated so
what i'm trying to say here let's say if
n was
if n was seven
and d is equal to say three
okay then six choose three right
can be written as
as uh
um what is it uh five choose two
plus 4 choose 2
plus 3 choose 2
plus 2 choose 2. okay
right that's right i mean n minus 1
choose d in this in this view has this
nice decomposition into sums
okay so i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the quadratic programming
okay
so same thing just the the quadratic
part has has included here now okay i'll
do the same substitution
okay i do that and this time i'll have
monomials in the support of the
following kind
hey what do i have now here i have first
two times the simplex
n minus d minus one simplex and then
and then
d copies of the of the standard unit
simplex shifted in the directions this
is the k the polar top capable top of
two times unit unit simplex and then
and then d times the the unit simplex
the copies of the unit template okay so
we can compute the volume of that
polytope okay by using the stick as
triangulation two
okay
but this time you get the exact same
thing with the with the volume factor
okay each one of those guys gonna have 2
to the k all right so that's the
ie i'm going to put here
okay the volume is going to be so it's
going to be
2 to the 0 plus 2 to the 1 2 square to
cube
okay so uh that gives us the the the
degree of the uh of the the central
curve for the quadratic program it's
very very close to to linear program in
form and then we get that so so in this
case then the pkk bound is exact exact
yep
general for generic data exactly
um i do i have
two minutes two minutes i have so
the triangulation so let me just point
out something here um in the case when
again q is a diagonal matrix okay we
also have the equations
equations for the central curve
okay we use a nice idea to to uh
eliminate the variables and i5 time i
can i explain it to you okay but i don't
have the time okay but the point here is
that uh
with respect to a degree reverse text
order okay expound is next to n let's
say for d is equal to two it is equal to
five i get the following graph now basis
plus of course ax equal to b
the equations right
the initial ideal
okay
is generated by those four monomials
here is the the decomposition
okay and if you add up the degrees it's
going to be equal to 11. it should be
the case okay
uh if you erase the twos
okay you're going to get the broken
circuit complex
okay of the uniform metroid
uh
of rank three on five elements
okay so
so using actual degree bounds okay we
were able to prove that these are the
equations that define the curve the
curve as well okay i'll start with that
thank you very much
so any quick questions
yes cynthia um
so this this thing that these equations
define uh doesn't depend on b
no it depends so so so you see there's
numbers here
the numbers here so what doesn't depend
is that is the terms do not depend so i
chose a specific uh problem but i
generated my b's and c's randomly and
and with my
my uh
equations
uh earlier
and you could
eliminate
um
these sort of this long equation with
lambdas and c's and y's and all
um didn't have any bees in them right
um oh i see
um
that is correct yes i was wondering if
there was nothing right exactly this
this doesn't have any data that comes
from from b i agree with you right i'm
sure you have like a sort of geometric
description of what this
large variety is
yeah this is sort of the this is now the
central sheet right for the quadratic
programming so the product from b is is
just slices you slice this yeah with x
equal to b then i slice it that's slices
that's right but this you're right this
doesn't doesn't contain these essential
sheets
uh
i mean it is the central sheet you know
i'm calling the central sheet
but i i don't have uh anything like that
that comes from like
uh spires and and brought food so type
of result i don't have that yeah but
it's i mean this this monomial ideal
hence hence this initial ideal for this
for this guy in general you know this is
a this is a common calling
initial idea
okay
so we can compute the h h uh
uh vectors and and in fact so that
actually can get a good bound on the
uh on the on the
central curve
any other questions yes matt yeah so you
you mentioned that this is for all
generic data yeah so then what about if
you say for that q term uh that q matrix
what if this guy was sort of ranked
efficient i mean so it's no longer
generic anymore how does this affect
things it should go down but uh i don't
know how
how in a controlled way it's going to go
down i think the curve would still be
irreducible then or do you think it
might split up into different
irreducible components or
i don't know
all right let's thank circa